er ist bei seinen menschen im land das
ist die botschaft und das tut er nicht
mit martialischen worten sondern das tut
er mit sehr klaren worten an den westen
und gleichzeitig mit worten die für
gemeinschaft sorgen in der ukraine
gestern am abend hatte er ein interview
gegeben ein fernsehinterview den
kollegen von ziehen schauen sie rein in
die worte des ukrainischen präsidenten
was die sperrung des luftraumes angeht
das hat uns sehr geholfen und das ist
kein hineinziehen der nato-länder in den
krieg ehrlich gesagt der massive krieg
geht schon längst und alle sind in den
krieg hineingezogen und nicht von der
ukraine sondern von russland das ist ein
totaler krieg und alle glauben dass der
schnell vorbei sein wird wir haben
mehrmals mit präsident beiden gesprochen
und ich bin ihm dankbar für alle
möglichkeiten und hilfe aber ich wurde
nicht gehört und ich habe gesagt dass
ukraine am stärksten kämpfen wird und
ihr werdet das sehen aber allein gegen
russland zu kämpfen schaffen wir einfach
nicht wenn ich über russland spreche ich
spreche nicht vom russischen volk
sondern von der armee russland
russischen regierung und so weiter weil
es unter bürgern russlands auch menschen
mit guten einstellungen zur ukraine gibt
sie unterstützen uns auch sehen sie
selbst die menschen die zu
demonstrationen also hier ist wichtig
einfach zu wissen dass wenn die ukraine
fällt dann werden diese alle truppen
russland an die grenzen der nato länder
stehen ein lied an polens grenze und so
weiter repro wurden stand axel brocke
[Musik]
da hatte dieselbe frage zu beantworten
und das wird andere große
bewährungsprobe für euch sein weil es zu
genau solchen provokationen kommen wird
deswegen ist der offene luftraum also
der geschlossen ist bedeutende
präventive sanktionen was wir damals
gesagt haben und jetzt wurden sie gott
sei dank eingeführt und wir sehen jetzt
welche auswirkungen sie auf russische
wirtschaft haben aber wir haben den
präsidenten der usa und die eu gewandt
führt diese sanktion ein früher
präventiv und ihr werdet sehen welche
reaktionen seitens russland gegeben wird
dass es zu einem angriff kommen wird und
mit russland zu verhandeln muss man am
tisch sitzen aber das geht nicht wenn
man bombardiert wird und die kampfjets
über den köpfen fliegen das sind ganz
verschiedene positionen da will jemand
und druck ausüben aber nicht richtig
verhandeln wir sind für einen fairen
dialog erst soll man die bombardierungen
von menschen stoppen und dann verhandeln
wir sind bereit über die
sicherheitsgarantien für ukraine zu
sprechen das hängt von unseren partnern
ab wenn sie nicht bereit sind die
ukraine in die nato aufzunehmen weil
dies russland nicht will aber es gibt es
sicherheitsgarantien die von allen für
die ukraine ausgearbeitet wurden was
bedeutet dass das bedeutet wir haben
unsere territoriale integrität nicht
wahr das bedeutet auch dass unsere
grenzen geschützt sind wir haben dann
besondere beziehungen mit den
nachbarländern
wir sind in voller sicherheit und
garantiegeber die uns sicherheit geben
sie garantieren dies rechtlich
wasserdicht